Félicitations.
Le fait d'être ici,
en train d'écouter , vivant,
un membre d'une espèce en pleine croissance,
vous êtes l'un des plus grands gagnants de l'histoire -
l'aboutissement d'une histoire à succès qui dure depuis quatre milliards d'années.
Vous représentez 1%.
Les perdants,
99% des espèces qui ont vécu,
sont mortes --
tuées par le feu, l'inondation, les astéroïdes,
la prédation, la famine, la glace, la chaleur
et l'effet délétère de la sélection naturelle.
Vos ancêtres,
remontant aux premiers poissons,
ont surmonté tous ces défis.
Vous êtes ici grâce à des opportunités en or
rendues possibles par l'extinction massive.
(Rires)
C'est vrai.
La même chose est vraie pour vos co-gagnants et proches.
Les 34 000 variétés de poissons.
Comment avons-nous été si chanceux ?
Continuerons-nous à gagner ?
Je suis une paléobiologiste qui utilise des big data --
les archives fossiles --
pour étudier la façon dont certaines espèces gagnent et d'autres non.
Le vivant ne peut pas le dire : ils ne savent rien si ce n'est gagner.
Alors, nous devons parler aux morts.
Comment faisons-nous parler les poissons morts ?
Des musées contiennent des centaines de poissons fossiles magnifiques
mais leur beauté réelle apparaît
quand on les combine avec le plus grand nombre de fossiles laids et brisés,
et qu'on les réduit à des uns et des zéros.
Je peux remonter jusqu'à 500 millions d'années pour des modèles évolutifs.
Par exemple,
des formes de poissons peuvent être capturés par coordonnées
et transformées afin de révéler les voies majeures de changement
et les tendances dans le temps.
C'est l'histoire des gagnants et des perdants
d'un événement central que j'ai découvert en utilisant des données fossiles.
Revenons 360 millions d'années en arrière -
six fois plus loin que le dernier dinosaure --
à la période Dévonienne,
un monde étrange.
Les prédateurs armés de mâchoires aiguisées ont dominé
aux côtés des gros poissons avec des os de bras dans leur nageoires.
Des poissons ayant l'aspect de crabes se sont enfuis au fond de la mer.
Les quelques parents des nageoires rayées de saumon et de thon
se sont recroquevillés au bas de la chaine alimentaire.
Les premiers requins ont vécu près du littoral dans la peur.
Vos ancêtres à quatre pattes, les tétrapodes,
se sont battus dans les plaines des rivières tropicales
Les écosystèmes étaient surpeuplés.
Il n'y avait pas d'échappatoire,
ni d'opportunité à l'horizon.
Alors le monde s'est arrêté.
(Rires)
Non, c'est une bonne chose.
96% de toutes les espèces de poissons sont mortes
pendant l'événement Hangenberg, il y a 359 millions d'années,
un intervalle de feu et de glace.
Un monde bondé a été perturbé et balayé.
Maintenant, vous pensez que l'histoire prend fin.
Le puissant est vaincu, la Terre appartient aux gentils, et nous voilà.
Mais gagner n'est pas une chose simple.
La poignée de survivants descend de plusieurs groupes --
tous en infériorité numérique pour leurs propres morts.
Ils allaient du grand prédateur au nourrisseur inferieur,
du grand au petit,
de l'eau de mer à l'eau douce.
L'extinction était un filtre.
Cela a seulement tracé la voie.
L'important était ce que les survivants ont fait sur les millions d'années après
dans ce monde dévasté.
Les vieux dominateurs auraient dû avoir un avantage.
Ils sont devenus plus grands,
stockant de l'énergie,
investissant dans leurs petits,
se répandant à travers le globe,
se régalant de poissons,
gardant ce qui avait toujours marché, et attendant le bon moment.
Encore ils n'ont qu'à persister pendant un certain temps,
déclinant sans innover,
devenant des fossiles vivants.
Ils étaient trop coincés dans leurs voies
et sont en grande partie oubliés.
Quelques requins à nageoires rayées, et tétrapodes à quatre pattes
sont allés dans la direction opposée.
ils sont devenus plus petits --
vivant rapidement, mourant jeunes,
mangeant peu et reproduisant rapidement.
Ils ont essayé de nouveaux aliments,
différents habitats,
têtes étranges et corps mystérieux.
(Rires)
Et ils ont trouvé l'occasion, proliféré,
et gagné l'avenir pour leurs 60 000 espèces vivantes,
y compris vous.
C'est pourquoi ils vous sont familiers.
Vous connaissez leurs noms.
Gagner n'est pas un hasard
ou une course aux armements.
Au contraire, les survivants ont cherché des alternatives aux voies de l'évolution.
Certains ont eu un succès incroyable,
tandis que d'autres sont devenus des poissons morts-vivants.
(Rires)
Un vrai terme scientifique.
Maintenant j'investigue
comment ces voies vers la victoire et la défaite se répètent à travers le temps.
Mon labo a déjà compilé des milliers et des milliers de poissons morts,
mais il en reste beaucoup.
Cependant, il est clair
que la survie de vos ancêtres de l'extinction massive,
et leurs réponses dans la foulée
ont fait qui vous êtes aujourd'hui.
Qu'est-ce que cela nous dit quant au futur ?
Aussi longtemps qu'une poignée d'espèces survit,
la vie se rétablira.
Le polyvalent et le chanceux ne seront pas exactement comme ce qui a été perdu,
mais gagneront dans d'autres formes.
cela prendra juste plusieurs millions d'années.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)